hola juan guerra 36 años
algunas aventuras he vivido en estos
últimos 18 años
en una palabra
de lograr que el ciento por uno el
universo
muchas veces han conspirado para hacer
que las cosas imposibles sucedan
hablando de cosas imposibles lo tuve me
topé con esta edad
la probabilidad es de 12 millones es
casi cero haber nacido es un milagro
entonces comparado con eso hoy tierra
estuviésemos enfrente de la vida
si contemplamos la imposibilidad también
el hecho de que la vida la tenemos ha
conectado
con la vida intensidad para ganar
a mi la vida 18 estaba en la calle
bueno fue gracias a ella y al terminar
la prepa saliendo de ahí
el cuarto continua
y no tenía ni para el camión para
probarte que texto
y en ese entonces me enteré que la
universidad en alemania era casi gratis
temblaba
dos semanas
es un camión dos horas después dzeko acá
y unas cuantas horas después ya iba de
camino a la embajada
pero trabaja en la embajada de tu
historia te va a ayudar lleva tres
semanas y de ahí se desencadena una
serie de milagros la razón
y poco más
[Aplausos]
no quise quedarme colgado
entonces
por cierto
cómo no
cuál es el plan de julio
d
y una cosa llevó a la otra colecta un
boleto a cuatro mil pesos y el concierto
fue un exitazo
muy agradecido a toda la comunidad que
me apoyó adelante
total tenía que mantener un par de meses
pero faltaba un papel el tofu
llegó
y el último semestre pero el gusto de
poder pasar el colonia
maravilla
romper las reglas cuando muchísimo por
esas fechas me topé con la historia
y servicios financieros para la gente
mejor seguridad quiero regresar a méxico
entonces estuve buscando
aprendizaje muy intenso y tan pronto
redes instalados yo estaba pensando en
que seguía que sé quién me quería ir a
hacer te envié al extranjero todos mis
colegas
es mucho más razonable la gente te dice
ser razonable eso es una invitación a la
mediocridad nunca sea razonable
lucha por lo que buscas luche por lo que
quiere es el peor es que fallas que te
quedes con la que hubiera sido su
derecha un poco más de ganas y yo no fui
razonable después de tres años de estar
mandando solicitudes a todos lados me
cayó la beca del gobierno británico y
héctor de casma nacional deducciones aún
así me faltaba una lana nica 10.000
libras mejor que el aula de la
universidad wigan faltan 10.000 presten
balanzas y la universidad no nos damos
créditos le damos una beca de 5 no no no
tanto me regaló dinero prestado el
dinero se los pagó bien de las 10
entonces que no prestamos saquen una
licencia de ti tanta lata que mente no
saben que ellas ya los tienes altos te
damos las días de benavente para acá
entonces como los digo que estaban con
mucha lata
inglaterra
horrores también y al equipo de rugby me
rompieron una costilla pero no me quedé
con la duda
la pena es muy padre chamba una
aseguradora tenía una oficina que exista
el río acciones en la empresa y estaba
armado
pero lo único que hacía todo el día pons
que no sé de qué forma le ayudaban a mí
y yo sentía que después de tanto
esfuerzo de mis afiliados a la comunidad
que me ayudó tenido también un buen uso
del tiempo
y algo que me confrontó fue una vez que
fui al doctor y me dijo tu corazón
puede ser peligroso
no tengo tanto tiempo que ofrecer para
generar mi acto para agradecerle al
mundo todo lo que tengo todo lo que me
dio porque si bien no todo fue fácil
a pesar de las circunstancias progreso
de una carrera hasta la maestría
agradecer tal vez muy poco tiempo
afortunadamente no es nada grave es algo
sintomático mayor
yo no lo sabía si me comprometo con mi
inmortalidad me recordó que la vida es
un rato que hay que tener un impacto
entonces decidí dejar el confort en la
aseguradora para afrontar una empresa de
crédito estudiantil y ayudar a otros
chavos al poder hacer but caps de
programación maestrías etcétera y esto
me llevó al mundo del cine de 2012
una plataforma de acción colectivo en
londres el medieval ojo del huracán de
todo este movimiento y la mascota en
nuestra empresa fue el elefante así que
decidí lanzar la empresa
mons
es una campaña de crowdfunding interesa
travesti a elefante cruce de los alpes
grabó el vídeo me divertía horror
estuviera dicho grande con la empresa y
no me quedé con la duda estuve un año y
medio cuando piedra hasta que
impresionistas como si bronco ni otros
empezaron a apoyarnos
y eso cambió todo salíamos en el
periódico los ministros y demás fotos
con nosotros y ayudamos a cientos de
chavos que esta forma no hubieran podido
seguir estudiando con orgullo fue de lo
más bonito que he hecho en mi carrera
estaban subiendo los ojos yo sentía que
ya estábamos con los cuernos de la luna
ya todo iba a ser de bajadita ignorando
que del otro lado del río la empresa con
muchísimo más dinero copiando nuestro
modelo de negocio y en tres semanas el
gobierno británico ha publicado un
esquema de crédito
bueno tuve también el gusto de conocer a
miedo
entonces proyectos
pero al cerrar el changarro para mí
hasta que descubrí mi pasión por la
innovación de los servicios financieros
que puede reinventar trabajando con
santander y después me llamaron de sitio
para regresar a mexico ayudar a la
transformación digital estuve los
últimos tres años
disfrutándolo un montón fue en esa época
que me vino a visitar una clínica de
londres
en la que yo me enamoré profundamente y
la esencia julio
no sé qué hacer
y dice
por favor y eso de ser razonable que
recordó queremos echarle los kilos
estuvimos lejos ocho meses cruzando el
charco cada vez que podíamos
y hoy les digo que estamos a horas o
días
[Música]
están por nacer y ahora profesionalmente
bien estuvimos contentos dando vida a un
proyecto que es un leo barco fruto de la
alianza de valor tierra
disfrutando los horrores si alguien me
hubiera preguntado hace 18 años qué iba
a hacer con mi vida nunca hubiera
imaginado nada de todo lo que les estoy
contando
lo que sí me ha funcionado en estos 18
años nunca si tienen un sueño vayan por
el en el ciento por ciento el universo
se va a encargar de conspirar a su favor
muchísimas gracias por todos